What do you do, when the sun turns wrong?
When light, which once represented life, joy,
and warmth becomes a symbol of death and destruction?
Do you hide inside, shutter the windows, keep
out the light by any means necessary?
Do you retreat underground, where the sun’s
rays cannot penetrate, burrowing into the
dark and the cold?
Do you simply give yourself to it, accept
that there is no escaping something so vast,
so far-reaching as sunlight itself, and allow
yourself to be lost in the end of all things?
We’ve covered this possibility before, SCP-001,
“When Day Breaks”, or S.D.
Locke’s Proposal.
It’s difficult to know what any given person
might do in such harrowing circumstances.
After all, we have always learned to love
the light and fear the darkness.
It turns our very understanding of reality
upside down to have that paradigm shifted,
the dark becoming safety and the light becoming
death.
The source of all life on earth, of all warmth,
transforming in an instant from the sun as
we know it to an Apollyon Class SCP that melts
all living organisms that cross into its gaze.
But what about a being that has always feared
the light?
Something that prioritizes solitude, and never
ever wants to be seen?
How might it live out those darkened days?
Today, we’re taking a look at what happens
when Daybreak meets a familiar face, even
if a constantly hidden one: SCP-096.
SCP-096, or “The Shy Guy,” is something
of a celebrity around here.
It is a humanoid creature with long, distended
arms, pale skin, and a jaw that can open four
times wider than an ordinary human’s.
There is only one thing, above all else, that
this entity desires: for no one to see its
face.
When someone views its face, it flies into
an uncontrollable rage, and seems to have
no other option but to destroy the person
who has seen it.
So, it is unlikely that a creature so intent
on solitude would be in much danger from the
transformed sun.
In fact, it might even be a positive thing,
and for some time it was.
With so many human beings gone, reduced to
gelatinous masses with no desire but to slither
around in the ghoulish sunlight and merge
with one another, there were fewer people
to observe his face than ever.
He could stay inside and know, with almost
complete certainty, that no one would come
to bother him.
No one was coming to look at him, and there
were no more visitors, researchers poking
and prodding, that might sneak a look at his
face.
And so, he stayed there, in the room that
had served as his containment unit before
the world turned upside down.
The masses of flesh that once were humans
did not concern him, as they never looked
at his face.
All he did was stay in his room, and never
go outside.
The outside frightened him terribly, though
he was not concerned with the deadly sunlight
or the possibility of it melting him as it
had so many others.
He was much more afraid that someone, some
unlikely survivor clinging to their original
life, might look at him.
That they might see his face.
That was simply too distressing to risk.
He would much rather stay alone, in his old
cell, weeping softly in the shadows.
One day, though we couldn’t say how many
days after the end of things it had been,
he was weeping alone in his former cell.
The days blurred together, spent the same
way, and time had lost much of its meaning.
Through the echoing sound of his sobs, and
the sloshing sounds of the creatures outside,
a woman’s voice cut through.
It was faint, but he could make out what she
was saying.
She was calling out for help, asking if anyone
had any food or fresh water.
The sound was getting louder, closer, accompanied
by the disconcerting thump of her footsteps.
She was coming down the hall, as much as it
could be called a hall anymore.
She was coming toward his room, to disrupt
his miserable peace.
He heard her steps cross the threshold of
his room, and her voice broke into a terrified
scream, no doubt at the unexpected sight of
a pale, naked creature weeping in the corner
of what she expected to be an empty room.
Startled by the first loud sound he’d heard
in a long time, in a world that had mostly
been silent since the initial outpouring of
agonized screams had faded into the soft slap
of flesh and slime on the ground, he turned
around.
He shouldn’t, ordinarily he wouldn’t,
but he couldn’t stop himself.
There, he saw a woman, wide eyes filled with
tears, face streaked with dirt, a small child
next to her holding her hand and clinging
to her leg.
Just as he saw the woman, she saw him.
She saw…his face.
Anger boiled over inside of him, and he let
out a scream, wild, primal, and filled with
inhuman rage.
She could not be looking at him, seeing his
face.
He couldn’t let her.
The woman ran with the child in tow, panicked
by the wild roar and the sight of him standing
upright before her.
The anger faded as she left his site, making
her way down the hall and to the stairs.
But then, he remembered: she had seen his
face.
He could not let her leave.
It was time to do something he never thought
he’d have to do again: hunt.
His heightened senses picked up the sound
of muffled footsteps, coming up through the
floor below him.
She was downstairs, just beneath the floor
where he was standing.
His instincts kicked in, and his body moved
almost of its own accord.
He lifted his long, long arms above his head,
and drove his hands down into the floor.
It was weakened by the ravages of the elements
and time, and crumbled under his unnatural
strength.
He dug his claws into the plaster, tearing
it apart and cracking it into pieces.
He pushed his claws in, deeper and deeper,
until he could feel them breaking through
to the other side.
He pulled the floor apart until the hole was
wide enough to fit through, then dropped down
to the room below.
He spotted the woman’s back, fleeing through
the door, just as he landed.
She was getting away!
He tore after her, ripping through concrete
and steel, destroying everything in his path
in a mad dash for the object of his rage.
He had to catch her, she could not be allowed
to leave.
She looked over her shoulder at him, her face
a mask of pure terror.
She knew, just as he knew, that there was
no escape in sight.
In his single-minded obsession, and her desperation
to escape from him, neither of them noticed
that she had run so far and so carelessly
that she was now outside of the building.
She had crossed from the shadows, into the
harsh light of the sun.
The woman’s eyes widened in grim understanding
of her fate.
He could only watch, helplessly, as her body
began to succumb to the vicious rays.
Almost instantly, she began to melt.
As it was the closest to the sun, her head
was the first to go.
Her nose drooped like hot wax, dripping as
it went until it slumped off her face and
landed on the ground with a sickening splash.
Her eyes were next, popping out of their sockets
and hanging, loose and limp, on her cheeks
and dangling from sinewy strands.
She tried, in vain, to stuff them back into
place, but they squished in her hands like
overripe fruit.
She attempted to run into the comparative
safety of the ruined building, but her feet
were already beginning to spread out onto
the street, melting into a sticky red smear
on the pavement.
Her legs crumbled beneath her, and she collapsed
to the ground, her face leaving a trail of
gelatinous flesh as it landed.
She tried, uselessly, to drag herself along
the ground back into the darkness, but her
arms were melting into the dirt, mixing with
it into a horrible red mud.
She let out a last scream of agony, but the
sound turned to a thick gurgle as her lips
fused together and her mouth melted into nothingness.
He watched it all, sobbing and roaring in
frustration.
She was gone, and he would never get the satisfaction
of ending her.
The infernal sun had stolen her from him.
Now she was nothing but a wet shadow, like
the rest of the humans had become long ago.
He heard the sound of a soft sob behind him,
a tiny human voice.
He turned, looking for the source.
There, was the little girl.
He had almost forgotten about her.
She was calling out for her mother and crying,
and she was looking right at him.
Right at his face.
He waited for the anger to overtake him, but
instead…there was nothing.
Why wasn’t he angry?
She was looking at his face, so why?
Then he realized: her eyes were on him, but
she did not see him.
She was blind.
She approached the creature, her arms outstretched,
following the sound of his crying.
She touched his hand with her own tiny fingers,
so small and fragile, and asked, “Mommy?”
Then, he felt something he had never felt
before.
Tenderness, care, a desire to protect this
tiny innocent being.
It was the first time he had ever felt warm,
ever felt anything but sadness, anger, or
fear.
Overcome with this softness, he wrapped his
arms around the child and hugged her close.
She hugged him back, tightly, and the room
went quiet as they both stopped crying.
From that day on, they became a family of
sorts.
They lived together, and he took care of her.
She didn’t know what he looked like, and
had no idea he might be something to fear.
To her, he was safety.
He was home.
For the first time in his long, awful life,
he felt like a human instead of a monster.
He would scavenge food for her, bring her
fresh water, lay down stolen blankets and
pillows so she would have a soft place to
rest.
He even found her a ratty, worn teddy bear
amongst the rubble and gave it to her as a
gift.
She clutched it to her chest and thanked him,
and for once his tears were those of joy.
In this cursed world, they had found something
like happiness in one another.
He knew he would protect her no matter what.
Then, one day, everything changed.
The creature and the little girl were playing
in the abandoned site, making up little games
together, when he took a break to look out
the window and monitor their surroundings.
Outside, the evil red sun waited.
When he turned back, the little girl was gone.
One of the shadowy creatures, once human,
was imitating his voice to lure her away.
He could hear it in the distance, and her
tiny footsteps following it.
He chased after her, the only thing he had
ever loved, and saw her just as she stepped
out into the light.
She screamed as one of her arms began to melt
in the light, and he knew what he had to do.
He grabbed her and pulled her back inside,
using his body to shield her from the horrible
rays.
As he wept over her, his tears stopped her
body from melting any further, but his body
continued to fall apart.
It was too late for him.
He ran, as far away as he could.
Once he transformed, he did not want to end
up hurting the girl.
He ran until his legs melted away and he could
not run anymore.
He had reached the shoreline, and stared out
at the ocean, unable to move any more.
He screamed, a final time, in agony, in heartbreak,
in mourning for the happiness he had finally
found and now would lose.
But at least he knew, as his eyes melted away
and he was nearly gone, that the girl would
be safe.
And then, he was gone, and the world was quiet.
Now go check out “SCP-096 – The Shy Guy”
and “SCP-001 - When Day Breaks” for more
on The Shy Guy and the SCP-001 proposal that
turned the sun against all of human life.